来,一条视频,把短视频的底层逻辑给大家讲清楚
这条视频有点危险,因为我以往只要想讲这个
我基本上就会被太走
不过不管了,反正我就讲讲的
我讲了你查了,什么我的故事讲了,是吧,还是这个情况
来
短视频这个江湖里呢,这个世界里呢,它是由三个角色的
那三个角色的一个是你引引
一个的平台,然后一个是永呼
所以这三个,它之前是要平衡的
我们很多人的问题在哪呢
就是老想的自己
我要有留亮,我要赚钱
你没考虑别人
在这个江湖是容不下你的
对吧,你再给别人有假设
你经常在这个江湖里生存嘛
所以平台要什么
平台你要明白它不是搞死死的,它背后是公司
公司是要有利益的
对不对,所以它要跳两个东西,哪两个东西呢
跟一个东西,它要商业价值
第2个,它要用乎的主义力,就这个时候主义力是最重要的东西
所以,你在做短视频之前,你要想清楚
我是能提供商业价值的
我还是能给它带来用乎的主义力
你拿我来说呢
因为我又不卖火,就不控告,所以我没有商业价值
我就属于另外一种,什么呢?就是我能给它带来更多的用乎的主义力
把用乎留在这个平台,要完我去别的平台了,对吧
这就好像去商场一样,好多人说,你头什么呢?你头前了吗?你这干什么呢?
你从底下,干嘛就不同
你去很多商场
那很多商场里面如果你在那个商场里带着,就会有用过来
商场是不收你钱的,他也给你钱
这回动了吧,所以拿我来说的话呢,我其实属于
属于后一种,就是能给他带来用乎的
反正我能给他带来用乎,所以他可以给我放工资
所以各位第一件事情,做的让平平台之前
且上,我能给公司带来什么?
利论
二主义力,当然两个都可以打,你像我这打了一个,就主义力
第二个就是用乎,用乎呢?它是有两种价值的
一种要过那么价值的一种要情绪价值
我看这东西真有用,我的人身罢了那一边,一种就是我也不订
你都一不订有用
但是我看了你,我就开心
我看,对吧,你有什么不开心的设计,讲一讲,让我开心一下
这种,当然你计划,是共价值又属于情绪价值
你像我这种就属于公价值,我选择公价值
因为哪个给别人情绪价值,为什么要转烧我,给别人情绪价值呢?
我不是开心的时候也会听情绪价值
所以,你还要得画另外一个,就是你能给用乎,在在光价值还是情绪价值
就像你看,你在这,你看在这,我在这
对吧,我们很觉得那边在哪,我想赚钱,我钱有留量,你对人家都没用,没用人家
你能容了一下你吗?
对吧,容不价,你也想,那还要一个就是,我还有什么价值
对吧,这是我们
好,这是第一段,大家听懂的吧,然后不价,第二段,就是九个东西,就是算法
就好多人都看算法,算法是什么东西
都是研究算法,怎么那么闹,我告诉你
这是不对的研究是要研究,但你不能把他太当回事,为什么因为算法是平排的代理
我这么讲,能听懂吧
这是,你许了以后要给用过的那件事,还要给我有价值
但是,这么多人,我怎么管得了,我怎么管得了呢?
我,我是你二大爷,我给你游战,不是这样的
他要通过算法来听懂
这个算法就是意志的体现
他是代理,所以简单来说你是要
联系这个算法的,这样你就有流量了,你对吧,好吧
那么我先讲的意思,但你又不能完全看算法,就至于不能完全看算法,我会被说
我们说算法的问题
他既然是个所谓,他就是
我的话还不能说的,那么清楚
还是可以印象工程的,那里面吧,但是可以印象工程的,就是
我们一种位置吧,谁做成了,对吧,第一个事情
就是,一种位置,谁做成了,你可以把它印象工程,他是怎么做的,然后去学习
AI,所以上场这个
第二个
太阳底下没有信心事,没有信心事,所以
本来是另一条,什么也好,他有些东西
就是在电影,在文区的作品里面都出现了,本身上就是
注意力嘛
所以
文章是怎么开头的
电影是怎么开头的,信心单口,像上,说,脱脱幽
是怎么开头的
怎么把你流露的,怎么让你
我好开心的
其实都是可以见面的
加上AI的女生
然后你就会有结果,所以不是学人家的
怎么说我的,而是学那个结构
我怎么
让你愿意看的
怎么把你留在这儿,跟你愿意跟我聊天了
怎么让你有感觉的,对吧
大人是记住了
算法他们,他挺笨的
你们说,算法人工真的那么聪明的,没错,很聪明
但他有时候又很笨,为什么他没有敢施能力
他没有敢施,他没有把它敢施能能能不能好白的怀
他只是看数据数据来自什么数据来自用户的行为,不是一个用户两个用户
一堆用户
行为
所以你不能广看结构
你不能说,我这听我有用,为什么,有没有用,有有有我承认
但是
算法他只认行为,什么行为啊,这个地方好
小心心
你不要跟你,不要跟你聊聊好了
我来这东西,打着这边这家
我觉得你这边值得关注,我收插回去看一看
这,他是来着一哲的
所以你的东西最好,如果没有触发行为,没有转发行为
好不好好,怎么用
能力量,你没,他只理解这个东西
那,那,那些话
但是我又说,你不能完全看这个,为什么
因为算法会变的
他会根据外移的环境变的,所以你要看他同事,你要理解刚才我说的东西
背后我是给平台的
什么,什么
给用户的,什么,价值他怎么重要的行为,所以有个结构之后,你看了之后
你可以学别人的东西拿过来,他是咱们写开头的,文章,我说的是文章,文章怎么写开头呢
文章怎么写结构呢,文章中间的结构过程怎么写的
不知光周一这个说算,你还要理解,为什么他写这儿的时候人家会
给一下信心
为什么到这儿说,他偷,他没想跟你
为什么写这儿说,我听说别相比
你一定要看那个结构最后转化行为的那个底眼
那个情侣的底眼,就是人性是不别眼的人,这事,这事不别眼的
对吧,作为你要看,你要收集很多东西,这个时候会引发什么行为的,放在开头,这个是和流存,这个是和让英国产生,什么动作
放在什么地方,你就会有这样的树在后,你的树台越多的时候,你的结构有了,你的商业理解有了,慢慢,慢慢
他就会形成一套系统,刚才是这个行为很简陋,很简陋,但是你会发现,他只有一个小结构,然后开始不再加不再加不再加不再加不再加,他就会有了结构
有在结构以后就会有飞舍,你拿我来说,我个人呢,我自己很久了,我给你把那个东西复盘一下啊,我给平台带在什么价值,两个价值,一个是利益的价值,一个是利益的价值,一个是利益,一个是利益,关注度的价值,对吧,我给平台带来的是关注度的价值
我和平台带在相互上就,他给我留亮,我给他留亮,很神奇吧,第二件事情,我给用过带了什么功能的价值,偶尔来的情侣价值
我带里面可以透过的什么,我可能会挣钱,我可能会带来印象的,我获得印象的一口主义力
对吧,我这个平台购建起来的之后的话,我基本上就是一个文章爱怎么写,一条视频该怎么拍啊,我基本上都有了,这个都记复合算了,有否合理,有算方的理解
所以我的概念是什么事,我只关注我,我去做自己的事了
我只需要去做,我要生活呀,做自己的事,我喜欢的事,我把我做的事有一些好东西,我遇到问题怎么解决到分音出来,是能给用过带来加除了
给用过带来加的话,有否合理的旗合够,同时偶尔会有些行为,那算法就会给我
那么平台觉得很好,他就我们就心中这样一个,一个很好的,这个理认,就是,走了好了,飞车的机会吧,那点一定要替回啊
不要靠力气,靠力气你每天会很累,靠系统你也会,你就会很挺足,所以你每天就要去,你现在就一定懂那个工具之后,每天就要拆结构了
好了,才结构,开头怎么开头,才能什么经历,符合使力的,符合使力的利益这个地方,为什么会流出人,用了什么的机构,符合使力的利益
这个地方,他,我怎么就介绍为,怎么让用过产生动作,动作符合算法,然后符合使力的利益,把这个,那就来,你才算法,短视频吧,明白了